hi everyone now most guys will either be
coffee lovers
or tea lovers i am definitely a coffee
lover
but there are amazing benefits with
certainties that will greatly boost your
life that is if you just know what to
drink
you will sleep better think better
stress less
and your health will be a lot better
now let me quickly show you the three
besties that you can drink for your
health now these are of course my
favorite
[Music]
number one is green tea
i used to
i didn't like it at all i mean
but then i learned to drink it in china
green tea will help you to lose weight
and kill the bacteria that causes bad
breath now those two benefits are my
favorite but it also helps repress
angiotensin because of high blood
pressure it lowers the risk of
osteoporosis and the antioxidants in
green tea may decrease the risk of
cancer and then drinking around four
cups a day
could help prevent prostate pancreatic
bladder and stomach cancers
the next one is
boss this is my language afrikaans and
this
tea comes from south africa so say it
with me rui boss don't say right bosh
right boss now
the direct translation is red bush this
is by far my most favorite tea because
it doesn't contain any caffeine so it
calms me down i drink this especially at
night
it contains a lot of antioxidants that
stop free radicals from damaging the
cells in your body it's also important
for a healthy heart and the antioxidants
anti-inflammatory properties
help to reduce inflammation and feelings
of pains
then if you want to lose weight it can
also help you to lose weight because
every let's say cup of ruebos only
contains around two to four calories but
then just don't add any sugar
rebosti also has alpha hydroxy acid
which is used in skin treatments such as
chemical peels so it's good for your
skin as well and i've also heard other
people say that you can also use it to
help with allergies
colic digestive problems mental health
issues
and poor appetite
now the next t is hibiscus tea i hope
that i'm pronouncing that correctly but
have you ever tried this tea
according to medical news today it has
antioxidant and anti-tomorrow effects
it may protect you against the aging
action of free radicals at a cellular
level as well as fight certain types of
leukemia cells
it has a lot of antioxidants so it can
also help you with your blood pressure
there's a lot of other benefits as well
too many to actually list here but there
are also studies that show that it can
help you with skin cancer and prostate
cancer
now these are my favorite teas but other
good options are ginger tea for your gut
herbal tea for lung health and
peppermint tea for sickness now for you
guys who love coffee if you want to know
the health facts about coffee if it
really is healthy or not i mean i'm a
coffee lover i've done some studies on
this check out this video here it's a
little bit older but the information is
good oh yeah and if you haven't
subscribed yet please subscribe because
chances are you'll like the other videos
on my channel as well before you go
always remember
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys